gang we're about to kick off the second
leg of that state trashy tour oh yeah
coming into the home stretch so don't be
left out in the cold make sure you get
your tickets stand up comedy plus you
play the late YG with the crowd great
way to introduce two people to the show
so grab the squad come out and see the
boys yeah guys we're gonna be in uh
Pittsburgh Buffalo Toronto we're doing
just added a third show in Toronto get
tickets tonight because they're moving
we got Pontiac Michigan Chicago Illinois
fourth show being out of there get those
tickets Minneapolis Madison Milwaukee
Sacramento Sacramento San Francisco San
Jose then we're we're ending it and
Philly baby with a bang we added a
second show with the Fillmore that's
more than halfway sold out get those
tickets let's party go Birds welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit there with your favorite
comedians and we find that the group to
be classy aren't there just a big old
piece of trash I'm your host Dave Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
out back here at hoodies in the new
edition she is upstairs watching a
little Dog the Bounty Hunter okay just
relaxing you know doing her thing my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me he's the flatbread freak giving up
for KJ Kevin James Ryan oh The Abridged
version I know hey what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in I am nervous over
here can't see if you can pick up on
that uh shout out there uh make sure you
rate you subscribe on iTunes full video
available YouTube version of those
numbers are cooking
obviously the greatest website of all
time
www.patreon.com garbage guy and get
signed up over there you get a bajillion
hours worth of bonus content I'm talking
heavy bike it's a good time gang check
it out and having a nice quick shout out
to our producer extraordinaire the old
magic man makes us all look good works
the ones the twos the threes and the
fours he crosses the t's in the
lowercase Jades give it up for T-Bone
mcgruffins Toby McMullen everybody what
up dudes what up dude what's up kid
another man we got the Maestro Mayhem in
here dude
he's making sure that I bomb on my intro
I'll tell you that much
gang we could be more excited to have
our incredibly and I mean incredibly
special guest back with us again today
[Laughter]
he is the jazz legend
looking more homeless than usual and
he's on tour right now the wrong side of
History tour give it up for Mr Ari
shaffir hey Ari how are you pal you're
out guys thanks for asking okay I don't
know what's happening you guys uh over
the years have talked a lot of bullcrap
about a lot of people why why are you
half Muslim half asian
you look like you just crawled out of a
Subway tunnel you look like prison with
real sideways
I can't well I can't quite get that but
you've judged a lot of people over the
years and I feel like no one's ever
stuck it to you okay okay what I'd like
to do is ask you guys that's today's
property of Ari shaffir Esquire and
there's one thing written on it
I'd like to uh I'd like to ask you guys
some questions today if you don't mind
because some things I think me and the
fans can I borrow a dollar
can I get this [__] button working
yeah that'll pull it together
my autism is gonna [__] not let me
move on until I get this button done
um and what kind of outfit would you say
that is and why are you shaking let's go
how much coffee did you have for that in
a few days I'm trying to fit into this
outfit my closet there you go it looks
beautiful
well guys uh long-standing Western
tradition is that of judgment okay okay
guys I just have a question for you guys
okay right ahead one or two give her a
remove the barf bag from a plane taking
it with me yeah taking it off the plane
ever in your lives yeah I have I don't
think so just for fun just to have he
doesn't have a pen after all this
the pen is the hitch in the stuff
stolen from what bank you have removed
the bar back from a plane I have
interesting to what end I don't know I
just took it just to have it just for
fun keep his toys in there yeah have you
ever taken one is that a crime I'll ask
the questions today
hahaha
I love I've said this every episode I
love and hate you so much it's fantastic
and I love and hate you guys please ask
a question have you ever smoked
cigarettes within six feet of an
occupied stroller yes yeah wow yeah
we're trash yeah where do you where do
you think I keep the Bernies
okay okay this is interesting hey what's
the difference in effect and effect with
an e or an A do you know that uh yes an
effect
is the outcome effect is the verb you
are affected by something that causes an
effect I concur with that smarts are
concur even if you know or don't know
okay I'm so nervous about this bag by
the way I'll be on Kent City
Indianapolis St Louis in Louisville
reading fortunes
um uh bring your own crystal ball
which I keep
do you keep food in your car
I don't keep it in there but there is
currently food in my car that I left
there today there might be like a bag of
pretzels or some chips or something in
the console definitely some cough drops
and gum if that counts I'm gonna count
maybe a pizza definite pretzel maybe a
pizza
okay have you seen every Fast and
Furious none wow none none and we asked
that question that's one of our first
one of the original questions of are you
garbage was how many of you seen in the
theater
because that yeah everybody's you catch
one or two you know what I mean flying
through on USA or TBS or something never
I think I've seen
the first three I think at the Tokyo
Drift I you know that's when I got into
it that's when you got into who gets
into it yeah hence the shirt yeah I love
Asian car culture I love Asian car
culture okay okay that's a no wow
surprising
okay I'll be in Tempe in Tucson in
december.com
selling turquoise jewelry
have you ever bought a knockoff item of
any kind yeah oh yeah uh for a while
when I was uh waiting tables on the
Upper East Side in the early 2000s a guy
would come around once a week with uh
fake Rolexes and fake watches would
always buy one
interesting yeah how much are they like
40 bucks uh I've definitely bought and
not real slash good jewelry you know but
it wasn't
a pure knockoff it was just like a 20
chain from the mall and every time and I
mean every time my mother comes up to
New York she buys bags and stuff off the
the guys on the street really with the
with the carpets out there yeah like the
records show that Kevin said uh said
button
[Laughter]
I'll be in Atlanta on 420 Nashville and
Charlotte come up right up there
um when you're wearing a suit do you
wear an undershirt oh no this is very
big yeah not a fact I think no no it
makes it worse layers yeah it makes it
worse oh I will and it's even trashier
which we've talked about before I will
take a crew neck regular white t-shirt
yeah cut the sleeves off oh
Jesus which gets worse cut the sleeves
off so you can't see them because you
can see the sleeve through the white
shirt when you take your jacket yeah
that's true but if you cut it here it
falls all right come on yeah it falls in
the seam so you got the protection of
the undergarment I will if it's a crew
neck I will also cut the neck around
here so you can't see the crew neck so I
can do an unbuttoned the crew neck is a
problem too so I cut the crew neck and
if this is typically you cut it like all
straight down I'll cut it to like here
like just like a deeper you you don't
like a V because the v-line can see the
V you can see so you do like a u which
is here so you can undo the first button
and it looks like there's nothing there
you don't get seen plus you can rip it
off when you're closing after the
wedding yeah I like the T-shirt so you
can not sweat into your suit sure sure
yeah are you a jacket on a jacket off
kind of guy at a wedding I'm a jacket on
yeah me too yeah I'll leave it on
because you always want the possibility
of turning it up and waving that suits I
was not expecting that a showman you
want it if they get you there you want
to be able to go there gotcha I agree
with that it's the energy level gets
there you don't want to be left open you
don't want to be running back to find
your jacket coincidentally the first
time I saw somebody do that was my buddy
Brad Kramer at a bar mitzvah very young
yeah dude it was suits and he pulled
that move and I was like God damn this
kid's all right yeah juice turn it up
they really do yeah and also you guys
have been to Jewish events right of
course Jewish weddings bar mitzvahs
Mitzvahs the dancing underrated it's
amazing for everyone to join in yeah put
on that you just join a circle
those guys were getting down eight
percent checking what you can't spell
Santander without an H
uh yeah what does that mean I'm saying I
don't know I figured Hebrew
those are interesting okay it's back at
a character why didn't you wear the suit
for this why well he wore a suit last
what is this what's the attire this is
uh where judgment started was in the Far
East but what does the the Hat have to
do with anything it's the closest I
could come to tying the outfit to go
there we'll go back to the drawing board
Chinese hat
um so I got this uh from Guatemala and I
brought it and I try to make it Far East
yeah I'm now realizing it didn't work I
didn't look at it it was from the east
side of Guatemala there it is from the
East
that is true that is true okay it's so
funny we were like what are we gonna do
with r today and I was like ah we'll
just hang sure as [__] [__] curveball
shafir have you uh have you ever
drinking a drink drunk drink drunken
drunks drinking drinking a fireball
yes yes I mean
there you go you have you are nuts if
you think I'm drinking anything that
came out of your bag specifically
I would normally I would it's sealed I I
don't yeah who knows what you're up to
yeah you probably got a ceiling machine
in that apartment of yours
gotta watch your drink around this guy I
probably do have a that's a good idea to
get a sealing machine sorry I think I
wouldn't put anything past you that's
what they say they do at Yankee Stadium
where like the Steel's crack but like
they figured that out and they're just
like they just solder it you know that
idea it was nice to feel Waters and just
solder it shut ah when they bring in
booze yeah yeah they just get the Asians
like we'll give you five cents each or
seven cents each for those bottles
instead of instead of five yeah you got
the little solder on it yeah fill them
up
strong man he brought he broke out four
[__] reserves okay where did you get
those closet okay I had them left over
from a Halloween where we were all in
his Batman and Batman had a working uh
belt utility belt fit in perfectly
airplane that's a lot of fun I don't
know where that got turned up dude we
had like 15 Batman I saw it Oh yeah
that's right yeah yeah DeRosa it was
great only problem with the Batman suit
um can't pay no pee hole yeah no it was
a onesie suit it was a onesie soup what
has Batman pee he can only when he's at
work yeah you can hold it yourself yeah
he's better than us or just goes in the
suit he's also not drinking nibs
he's on the job he's already hydrated
though knocking down ponies in the
Batmobile
which I guess Woodford Reserve I mean is
Woodford Reserve it's classic to be in a
little bottle is it plastic or west it's
plastic what is the classiest of the
airplane bottles I would this is I guess
Gray Goose because I think that's glass
I think the Gray Goose is glass to be
honest with glasses typically I feel you
get Smirnoff on the plane though it's
not 99 Bananas
every one of my aunts gets loose on that
at Fourth of July
have you ever been cut off on a plane
yes what yeah that was a fake question
oh yeah
wow that cut off we drank them out of
vodka wow so they were like Hey listen
it was a two-hour flight it was me my
brother and my cousin we're heavy booze
bags and they started they started
giving up because we were asking for so
many I forget what we were drinking
vodka tonics maybe or screwdrivers and
we were asking for so many that they
were given three of three little guy
three of these at a time to each of us
so we're doing nine a clip and I think
they only probably only had like 30 or
something so we did like three or four
rounds and they were like we're out of
vodka and we're Landing in 10 minutes
and you're at in altitude your tolerance
goes up right or down I don't know
mine's pretty it's pretty status I feel
like mine goes my tons goes up up there
I can just keep drinking it's nice you
don't stand you know you're not standing
yeah there's no different like they're
not in and out you're not smoking a cig
there's no like that's a cigar that
sends you over the top sure yeah
stepping outside me like oh I am [__]
up the change of it the change of
environment really I'm not really not a
[__] chick and having like look at you
weird and like no that's happening on a
plane no okay I got put on the bench
before we took off because I asked for a
second Bloody Mary before we took off
yeah he asked for a second double he's a
big Bloody Mary guy on a plane it's well
documented he's uh the one time we flew
to Orlando we did like 20 or like 18
Bloody Mary's really between the airport
bar and the plane wow I saw you guys at
the airport one time you were about to
go up for Bird yeah you were just now
you're so big bird opens for you
I love you Bert going on the cruise
everybody we were at the uh we were yeah
we were having breakfast at the Palm and
you walked by with a stolen bag of
almonds oh that's true he also forget
this oh yeah all up and he sits down
he's like airport breakfast oh new money
like
like I'm sitting there in a Rolls-Royce
or something he was dressed exactly like
this in the restaurant at the whole at
the airport
sandwich to go you can't steal the
restaurants a cup of coffee get your
head on straight yeah you're there we
have the time I want to relax I never
have the time I don't get there in time
really yeah we're there like an hour
early wow we have to we have to check
luggage there's five of us that travel
we have to check luggage oh yeah tobes
was there also yeah Toby Tommy new guy
Luke flies with us now so there's five
of us we have to give time in case
everybody gets there we have to check
all the gear gotta feed the boys yeah
yeah yeah you dick around too sure
I think it was play a little grab ass
get cut off at the airport have you ever
masturbated on a plane I have really yes
I had a buddy in jail uh shout out to
you and he would do this thing if they
would they so they would be in the cell
and they would do like the last call
they'd be like all right like final
inspection or whatever yeah and then
like walk the the plank or the yard no
the power of cells the cells like the
the hallway where all the cells are you
know what I mean what are we talking
about
I thought we were talking about planes
again yeah the guard would walk down and
do like a one last visual inspection and
the game in jail was to try to
masturbate before the guard got to your
to yourself because he'd stop you I
don't know that was just like that you
had nothing else to do so you were like
this is a time thing fun game fun game
and like it'd be like hey I'm in cell
nine I was able to get it done or
whatever you think there's an
understanding in prison when you hear
them
there's one in this office right now if
I hear that you could use the next door
new guy Luke is [__] going for it
wailing on himself
that's great I'll be taking a plane to
Denver Colorado that I'm doing February
and March two weeks so the Comedy Works
plug in 20 24 dates breaking the record
for straight shows of the comrade
February and March
uh is there currently a two liter soda
in either of your fridges no no that's
just cause my there would be but that's
just the life that's just what the wife
the wife is like yeah she's like that's
just like yeah very is there one in
yours I haven't why would you ever buy a
two liter of soda I don't know what are
you buying cans so yeah well I think New
York is very like individual you like
hey this is I'm having lunch I'm gonna
grab a bottle of whatever yeah no one
understands New York and the size the
amount of space we have oh yeah although
I'll tell you this man I haven't [__]
used a 2-liter yeah when would you yeah
I go back to there's why did we yeah
when the [__] if you got a lot of kids
in the house you want to keep going I
guess it'd be something like that that
man it's also way cheaper too like it's
cheaper instead of buying three 12 packs
if I opened a two liter of soda in
probably [__] 10 years I would make
sure I miss it I would make sure my mom
would buy them for gravity bong purposes
gravity bogs GBS dude I had a gravity
bong in central Washington State they
used to have a club out there
Jokers maybe something like that and
these guys are going to smoke weeds
making sure I went to their car had a
gravity bomb imagine this is a two liter
they cut the bottom off okay had uh uh
duct tape both both sides taped it this
way taped it that way stuck it to
himself and stuck it all the way in
and so then it was like that watch so
they lit the [__] bong out of the top
pulled the whole thing out yeah that's
how we did them oh yeah I thought we
started was with water and you go like
that yeah you pulled out of water yeah
there's no it just created a vacuum yeah
you could do in your car just created a
vacuum pull the tape out that's the
vacuum and then you put the thing in
your mouth and they just [__] it's
just all the smoke your eyes oh yeah
dude gravity bumps [__] you up gravity
bunks [__] you up that's usually the
last drug you do gravity bong yeah then
if I caught a bad gravity bong and stop
smoking weed that was dabs for me [__]
dabs dude they were so popular I took a
hit at a [__] Christmas party one
time man I thought I had a Christmas
party where you at it was like in the
Foley
international waters baby
that's great
this episode is brought to you by better
help gang anxiety can paralyze you which
I didn't know your fear unlocked okay
here we go I can't move my legs
no it's brutal I have it it sucks yep a
lot of people have it best way to handle
it talk it out a little bit better help
can help better help online therapy is
an amazing tool all you need to do is
take a quick quiz get matched up with a
licensed therapist and you will be on
your way yeah you can talk to your
therapist via video chat by the phone or
even just message however and whenever
you want the therapy is totally up to
you I said at once I said it two three
million times talk therapy is a
fantastic tool for a specific moment in
your life if forever whatever if it's
for a month if it's for a week a breakup
of this or that just something to get it
out you got to get that bad juju out of
you uh if you don't tell if you don't
gel with your first therapist you can
easily switch at any time for no
additional Chargers I've always been a
big fan of just getting the bill and if
you don't like them switch up or you're
already oh uh get a break from your
thoughts with better help visit
betterhelp.com garbage today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com garbage betterhelp.com
garbage do it gang okay let's talk about
that manscape baby shout out to the man
big fan they don't only take care of the
balls they take care of the face too
because I got a new product over there
they're always innovating they keep
moving they got the handyman gang if
you're going for the clean shaven look
but hate the mess and the hassle of a
wet shaved manscape has something for
you it's the handyman baby manscapes new
electronic shaver lets you shave up to
three days of growth no water no shaving
cream required nope and if you're short
on time the five minute Quick Charge
feature is a lifesaver and a
rechargeable battery lasts 60 Minutes a
runtime uh equipment manscape skin safe
technology to help reduce Nicks and cuts
listen it's for your face if you want a
clean shave
I say try your balls too you wanna you
wanna clean shave down there butthole
just [__] eat whatever whatever you
feel good be careful when you're doing
it just saying sometimes you need a bald
eagle from time to time if you're
swinging get somebody on the lookout uh
if you're on the go guy never leave the
handyman at home perfect for travel it's
both Compact and airplane friendly there
you go shave on a plane sure be a dirt
Peg have you no get 20 off and free
shipping with code garbage at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping at manscape.com code garbage do
it gang hit the refresh button with the
handyman back to the show yeah yeah it
is the most I'd say everyone with big
Jay and uh Christine once they would
talk they were saying how I was living
in L.A they're saying uh New York weed
was just as good as La weed that's just
wrong sure and I was like I'll give you
a mid high level weed not even the
highest level super blue dream it was
called we smoked out of a gravity bong
the skunk magazine gave us and we're all
just shivering yeah it'll turn the
lights off yeah yeah not a good feeling
I can feel but you really get your
money's worth on the on the weed it's
like all of it
yeah
oh yeah it pulls right through
yeah are you a big bong guy were you
like you got into like the three Footers
and the two Footers College that's a
college thing yeah but I think tell me
if I'm wrong I think it's now classy
again to bring it back as an adult you
get a nice bong like a nice glass piece
but it's got to be clean you gotta clean
it and it can't be too big like my my
buddies were doing what's there's that
famous one out of Aurora or something
Aurora stand over there and light it and
it was like a four-footer and then you
know it was like five thousand dollars
or something insane I'm saying here now
if you're entertaining your your your
wife's a one football a one foot glass
bomb clean on the table a bag of wheat
I'll give you two feet really light it
up clean it every time it's gotta be
clean it's classy again yeah we had a 12
got 12 foot one and 12 foot someone else
has the lighter second wave from one
floor to the other at the fraternity
house someone else would light it out
there light it downstairs and you'd be
at the top of the steps pulling it
good time were you a beer bong guy no I
just did one at the uh at the Cowboy
Giant game love a beer bong where we
passed with funnels we passed uh some
guys they're like oh shaffir and they
were doing funnels and I was like um I
started running season I'm like I'll be
right back you guys
I gotta go see a man about it we're
gonna go hang out with these teenagers
yeah they had naughty bows Maryland
Frank the Tank over here I'll see you in
five I gotta protect my rep yeah it goes
down so fast right as he's like let me
film no no dude this ain't about that
this is for the Love of the Game yeah
yeah exactly it was great though that
goes on so fast it's so good they're so
if you get at the right temp T-Bone was
always a big shotgun guy but not too
cold to wear like it hurts man you can
[__] crush them yeah we used to have
we used to make them we'd go to Home
Depot in like high school and buy a
funnel you could buy it you could buy
like two three foot of tubing or five
ten feet get that wire thing that you
screw and then we put a hinge on yeah
like a a valve you could buy like a
plastic PVC valve to keep it closed yeah
to keep it closed so you don't have to
bend it that was a problem you fill it
up and you're like oh [__] you're not
ready you gotta like see I thought you
meant like the little things that like
the metal things that you screw in it
well you would have that you'd have that
around the funnel obviously and then but
no you would just get you can put like a
PVC valve like a little like butterfly
valve or whatever turn it closed fill it
up let it let it seal made a little nose
grease in there we made a potato gun a
potato gun what do you mean to eat
give me a large fry shakas potatoes
right down your guzzle you don't have to
fry them why waste time frying when he
does have the starch they were mashed no
you never saw a potato gun looks like a
bazooka sure the big PVC yeah use
hairspray that's real making of them
like making a murderer type stuff wow
but speaking of this he'll be with me in
Minneapolis uh Madison Chicago and Iowa
City go see our Eagle remember tickets
on sale right are you on the road I am
on the road it's a long time History
tour
uh let's see what we got here for you
guys
um
see we got here I love them have you
ever taken a [__] on a plane yeah no
I'm shocked don't say I don't fit it
doesn't fit it's a physical thing yeah
that'd be bad news wow interesting yeah
yeah it would be bad news but you've
needed to I have needed to yeah
I needed to on the flight that we that I
just took to back from Greece and then I
got stuck in the Customs line so I
thought I was gonna [__] my pants
shikanaki yeah
what I did it on one of our trips and a
guy who was sitting by the bathroom
complained really nice well I mean watch
that that's the thing too it's like I'll
be in the front it'll be great it won't
be that great
I can't [__] on a plane I've done it
I've only done it flying to Europe but
it's it's like you have you have to it's
not like I'm going to [__] Buffalo I
can hold it for another year was it
diarrhea it wasn't great yeah
you know I'm always if I'm close to to
diarrhea a lot of times I'm never not
what's the line of diary over it's not
there what percentage of loose does it
have to be I'm not the guy to talk to
him about this
um
I think when the liquid phase but I mean
like obviously when it's like that's
diarrhea yeah but and when it's like
that's not diarrhea there's a there's
got to be a it's got to be a log for to
not for in my
a lot of times I'm half and half yeah
half and half Jesus
the plug the plug
the yesterday's food is fine
a little soup and salad
what are you a sick cat that's crazy
I do get it so the plug is yesterday's
meal yeah it's full it's fully done and
then the burrito bowls on them you had
rice for lunch you had burrito for
dinner yeah that's wild I am what I am
you're a meal and a [__] [__] per meal
no no okay now once a day usually wow
yeah once a day in the morning yeah I'm
using like a gentleman I'm yeah no
you're like nine times you're nine times
a day pee and poop a lot too you ever
think that's cancer yeah I'm leaning
diabetes but that's me
it's something irregular it's not great
it's not great no matter what something
keeping me from going to the doctor the
good news is not cancer the bad news is
you can't have flour tortillas anymore
no more Mike and eggs for you right like
have you ever by the way I'll be in uh
Detroit London uh Toronto Grand Rapids
uh Sudbury and Ottawa in April wrong
side of History tour on sale now our
history.com have you ever destroyed in
London
Detroit London Ontario
I'm like who's doing your routing dude
somebody's looking for you we got the
Magical Mystery Tour Bus
okay uh have you ever I'll be in Seattle
to Virginia Beach
have you ever snuck a cigarette indoors
at a public place yeah I just did that
at the UFC fight in Boston at the Garden
at the TD guard at the Boston Garden the
TD Bank Garden where how what uh well I
have good eyes for this I you know I
know a smoker when I see one I know uh I
know the flaws in the in the security
and I saw a guy with the Newport in his
ear and I was like you're not just
rolling around with the Newport with a
Newport New Year you're on a mission
yeah so he walked into a stairwell and
then I caught as I walked by the
stairwell I caught a whiff of some
[__] heaters so I go down there I
start smoking and then I hear like
chatter so like we go further down like
two more flights of stairs and there's
like a full-blown smoking Lounge heaters
in a stadium stairwell has a distinct
smell and that's allowed it really does
it should be allowed you're not
bothering anybody you're not bothering
anybody hey you're down here we're down
here we're gonna smoke cigs we're gonna
go people are smoking black there should
be and it doesn't affect anyone's day no
it's only only if you're a rules Monger
slash they should be a heater spot there
should be a heater spot yeah and the
fact there's not is like nobody's going
to just not smoke if you're a two pack a
day guy you're like it's everywhere how
many minutes is that and if you if you
were the stadium and people if you're
the stadium and people are drinking let
them have a heater they'll drink more
yeah yeah I don't think that's their
concern that you don't drink it enough
yeah I think their concern is the
legality but there should be a place to
go at least an in and out well they
don't give you an in and out most of
them are forcing us no one really has
them anymore like you know a lot of the
ballparks or football stadiums they'll
have the long ramp like this right that
like zigzags back and forth yeah yeah
you're talking about you were at the uh
Cowboy stadium they have that like the
long ramp yeah downed it you smoke while
you walk no you just go to the middle
point of one of those Rams so you can
see both sides you see both sides you
have a lookout you hang over the side
and usually you'll see a guy walking
like ah none of that you go all right
you take one last ball and flick it yeah
yeah that's that that's how I deal with
uh look the other way know what the
event staff doesn't give a [__] by the
way who's gonna say something to you
yeah
yeah that's how I deal with pissing on
the walk home after the seller later
tonight you walking p uh or I'll stop
but you go half a lot you go long blocks
not short blocks you can't go to busy
like Avenues you can't be paying on
Third Avenue but streets you go I'm most
of the way nobody's there I don't see
anybody coming here in a car I'm in
between the cars
yeah that's where you do it in between
the cars does that never occur to you
you're peeing on the wall
like between the cars yeah you go
between the cars that way you disappear
from the straight line of sight but
you're not even on the sidewalk if
anybody sees you you're just a guy
checking his oil yeah
hey rethink some [__] I write that down
what the hell kind of attorney are you
by the way let me see some credentials
man could you imagine being hemmed up
for something and this guy walked into
court to represent you dressed just like
this
you want a fireball I think we're gonna
lose this one
it's a good note it's a good note I'll
take that
I can't believe you haven't thought of
that no I just pee like either like in a
flower bed
you're a guy who thinks of so many
things well like so in-depth and then so
many blind spots it's so crazy and also
too you like you know the if there's a
apartment below yeah you just sneak down
there I think that's downstairs yeah I
wouldn't do that into their front porch
not their front porch it's like it goes
down and then it goes into the back of
the building
oh through you get a tunnel yeah a
little tunnel now like there's a place
to go there's places to go have you ever
tried to [__] public in in Manhattan
yeah there's like alleys but you can't
it's hard to find they're hard to find
underrated the bathroom at Union Hall
individual stalls oh yeah yeah okay ah
taking care of some business in there
did once lucky you yep drop the load
drop the load by the way second show
added in Boston uh Burlington Syracuse
Albany Foxwoods in February okay uh
good question go ahead buddy
it's fun I sure didn't have to do
anything has your credit card ever been
rejected yes recently this morning what
at Starbucks
my American Express why wow I thought
you weren't American
uh say the Pledge of Allegiance I say it
if you mean it uh my card's on automatic
payment yeah I didn't have enough funds
and I was saving this for hard feelings
I didn't have enough funds to cover the
automatic payment in my checking account
so it got rejected I got alerted of the
rejection I put the money about it nice
no I switched the money in it took the
money out it never reflected on American
Express's side so it's been getting
declined all week that sucks yeah so I
have a call ahead of me you have your
credit card your American Express card
on auto pay yes you pay the same amount
every month no I just pay the balance
and oh they can do that yeah you just
pay whatever whatever statement says no
kidding but that jams up when you don't
look at it and you don't have enough
money in there huh oh when you don't
have money in the in the CR in the
credit in my checking account I don't
have enough money
so he this morning got denied and you
have to do that because then it didn't
work you got to make an excuse to like I
don't know what's happening oh you did
know I didn't know I went new class a
new card
um were you getting food too that'd be
embarrassing I was a couple egg bites
cold bro
I'll just take the coffee but the worst
part was it didn't automatically you can
put the cake pops back I try to try
running again it didn't automatically
let me use a new card
it had to like he had to like clear it
out on his end and he was had his back
turn making my coffee so then he turned
around and be like here you go I was
like now you gotta [__] reboot that
so you gotta rerun that sale ah what a
gentleman wow do you have do you think
run at that point no no it was like
eight bucks yeah I got eight bucks yeah
yeah I think I did I don't but I did
glad you're running this operation what
about you keeping you fat all right uh
yeah for for a hotel my debit card shot
down now but it was uh they said it was
a uh fraud thing but they never alerted
me you know I still look like an [__]
you do look like an [__] oh there's
no way they did it they ran it twice
when they're like sorry if you're with a
chick with a friend you can't just be
like ah it's like I don't know it's a
credit card but it's not we've come
we've we've we've figured this out when
it's people who have money like who
really have money they don't worry they
don't bat an eye on it they say oh
here's another one or oh that's weird
they don't give you that they don't take
they don't feel obligated to give an
excuse what we do they just go oh my
banker [__] up here's another card
with a million dollars I'm sure you gave
it to Starbucks I have money yeah yeah
the rich go blame the Jews the poor go
oh I I'm somebody yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I just put ten thousand
on that account yeah
I'm a goddamn Millionaire right yeah
follow-up question do you have a backup
credit card just in case this [__]
happens
yeah I mean I use my debit card today
debit yeah yeah don't use debit use all
credit all credit cards why much as I
can because it's good I saw an Instagram
video where it's yeah it's also not it's
their money don't put the
every every banking institution above
like fifty dollars will will refund the
money okay yeah they will it is fun when
they just throw it right back do you
ever get tempted when they're like hey
you've been frauded you've been frauded
right sure okay I just got it yeah and
then they go hey which is the last
Choice do you ever get tempted to go let
me give one more
this one wasn't me either yeah nah
they'll catch you for that [__] won't
they nope but you could nope nope you've
done you've done it unofficially
unofficially have I got my lawyer here
sorry what can I say okay hold on
this is patient doctor client privilege
no this is real but he's heard this in
the past
yeah
for comedy purposes
[Laughter]
had gone to a nightclub
the 70s got a couple of couple of
bottles this man this man in the general
know of a specific man he needed to deny
this anyway yeah Studio 54 what are we
talking about how to charge more to his
credit his credit card than he could
truly afford you were doing not me this
guy who would die we're not talking
about anyone strike it it was a bottle
of beer by the way
belly up
uh you're talking to American Express I
didn't buy that Corona either
uh and then they were like I lost or the
person lost their card then later that
night or the next day and was like you
called he called the uh he she or they
called to replace it and they were like
well what was the last charge and the
guy lost it at like noon yesterday three
months ago that was me it's a borrows
I love where they hit you with like do
you know this like I don't know what the
[__] that is that's just how to do it
it's a company's parent company I just
had to do it the other day they're like
what was the last charge and I'm like I
don't I don't think about this the deli
for eight bucks I don't know I don't
know the names are good and how late was
it at night I'm like shut up dude shut
the [__] are there sandwiches over there
yeah by the way I've been in San
Francisco the Palace of Fine Arts in uh
January
um planting Museum
so we did vertigo
have you how's your family ever given or
received as a gift
a fruitcake
now
100 I'm sure I'm sure I don't know why I
always wanted to try one I've never had
one I don't get it it looks good it's
terrible I don't get it it's terrible
how could it'd be terrible there's it's
garbage it's garbage it's candied fruit
it's garbage uh meat of the of the cake
and then just a couple treats in there
huh the fruit is all you want to eat if
you can pick all those out but why don't
they just make a better base of the cake
they should ask veneros why they don't
make the [__] driest cookies what
were you doing with The Fruitcake that's
a Christmas thing was that my boys
friend's house robbing the place
and I was picking out fruit
um here's a question for you guys
um
do you have one question on every page
he jumps around I can't understand it
there was stuff crossed off before he
got here
this is a rough draft I feel like I feel
like you beta tested this and a couple
guys in Washington Square Park or
something like that you're just talking
to a homeless guy
okay let's talk about doordash shout out
to doordash my former employer gang it's
the fall things are getting hectic you
got the kids in school
sometimes it's a pain in the ass to get
over to the grocery store with doordash
you can have groceries delivered right
to your door anything you want easy
peasy and you skip the temper tantrums
like I got a deal when I take this one
to ShopRite guys uh we're big door Dash
fam over here like I said I used to
deliver for doordash shout out to you
also every time we go to a city boom we
we land throw a door Dash order in they
ship everything right to the house we
meet it there and look at us we're
making Eggies we're making bacon it's a
good time you've trusted doordash to
bring you nachos when you're drunk at
2AM now they're happy to help to stock
the pantry Pantry like a true friend
they've seen you through good times in
bed yes they have so sit back relax let
doordash bring you that head of lettuce
you need for dinner here's the turkey
gang get 50 off your first door Dash
order up to a 20 value when you use the
code garbage at ayg you check out I know
what I'm doing this weekend limited time
offer terms apply that's 50 off up to
twenty dollars no minimum subtotal and a
zero delivery fees on your first order
baby when you download the doordash app
in the app store and enter the code
garbage or ayg don't forget that's code
garbage or a YG they're doing both for
you for 50 off your first order with
doordash do it gang
have you ever tasted your own semen yeah
oh nice no just to try it it's a yes for
me no dude wow really never just throw
the size of both of you it's not Ben and
Jerry's man I'm not trying to get a
taste yeah I tried it you're not
thinking about it though yeah like an
old never wondered as a kid like an old
cop show when they test the drugs oh
that's good that's pure stuff yeah
you're going away for a long time
by the way looking at my dick how many
of you now as adults have done cocaine
yeah okay have you ever tried doing this
to see what it does and that back in the
day do anything no it doesn't do
anything yeah it's one I never
understood that it's a weird test yeah
also you would get high wouldn't you
what do you mean do you have to snort it
I don't think it's a test I think that
is like numbs your mouth no yeah it's
like they get like I don't know why
people never did that yeah it's a weird
cop
the cop thing it makes your man cops are
always like no they don't do that people
that are doing it do that cops touch it
on their tongue yeah I always thought
and I don't even I've never even done
cocaine but I thought I swear that
wasn't me with that credit card charge
either yeah uh either bottle service
over here it was the the least it was
like stuff that you couldn't snort like
the little residue on this yeah all
right well like let's not let that go to
waste oh there's that too for when you
catch like a heater or something what's
a heater
all right hands up everybody
detective Ari shafa
um wait do you ever hear anything about
Parliament lights with cocaine yeah yeah
do you think it's real no it is it's how
you find it's how you know who does coke
at the party no but I smoked it for a
long time so yeah exactly it's just a
recessed filter he says filter which I
love that oh man I really slob it of all
the brand loyalty ones parliaments are
the diff most different I thought it was
gross because people would bite on it
yeah but uh but a P Funk is what they're
known in the streets A P Funk everybody
go I'll do a P Funk like if you have
them they love it if you it doesn't it
could be Menthol non-menthal I'll do a
point it's like a fun it's like a party
it's a Jello shooter of smokables yes
I'll give you that always gave me a
headache really well that's a good
question was the last time you did a
jello shot oh let me tell you a fun
story so we were actually right over
through the last year opening game
What's it Mount Universe Montana okay uh
and we're like some guy was like my
friend uh Works in like catering so she
was like uh I'll have a friend he'll get
you a no tailgate like we should bring
some we made 200 Jello shooters there
you go that's great three full trays
worth and we walked around the Montana
Anna all over Missoula and just you
should see the people who definitely
love jello shots versus the people don't
care it was just a false it was like
whoa yeah and then we'd make him do
something we're like save the whales
save the whales and they're like what
what like jello shots save the whales
I'm like okay yeah
we got thrown out of an official uh
tailgate because they're like dude we're
selling alcohol in here like we can't
sell it I'm like we're not selling we're
giving them out because you gotta get
the [__] out of here man
people love jello shots they do people
it's a fun thing it's it's more
interactive it doesn't [__] you up it
doesn't matter it's like you're not
you're not it's not like doing a [__]
shot of wood for Reserve we're like ah
like you're like ah that was enjoyable
don't mind if I
there he goes
I got a great teacher crazy thing is you
got surgery after this can I move for a
new attorney please
yeah that's a good question
uh do you guys
you smell like my stepdad dude
I'm gonna try to kiss me later
[Laughter]
have you guys uh do you have any pairs
of underwear
you know where I'm going with this holes
in them that is true you've had this
question before have you yeah yeah
um I just know how many I just recently
uh got a whole new a couple packs shout
out to Goodfellows at Target great got
them all right now and they changed
their they changed their style so that
they can go they're like for bigger guys
a little dumpier in the Box yeah it'll
dumpier in the butt I like that what do
you mean it's bigger no they're more
they're more like old tighty whities
that kind of come up your back a little
bit interesting which I love they're
bigger in the seat yeah it's almost like
wearing it depends they [__] up with
like oh look at the models we're not
models yeah I don't want that [__]
Euro bikini [__] yeah I need some
coverage I got a pair of sheets give me
the wide shot you know what I mean I got
a pair of sheaths that I mean looks like
they went through a meat grinder but
they're so comfortable and this ain't
they're not even a sponsor this episode
yeah the thing is with sheaths is what
they're the best underwear around yeah I
don't have a podcast right now so I
don't have a sponsor so you can tell
this is true the camouflage sheaths
that's the ones I'm talking about are
the best at hiding dumps
jump stains of course oh yeah okay
unless it's snow camo it's upstairs the
red the blue blacks are quite good
actually but the camouflage it just
Blends in do you have that a lot you
have skid marks a lot he's got a bad not
a lot but often and when I have diarrhea
I will pick out the the camo sheath to
wear in case Jesus use your best it's
just leaking out of you leaking is a
good word
leaking is actually a great word it's a
great word
what's linking right now is take us from
my Parks Casino uh gigs October 21st and
outside Philadelphia
that's where I'm from it's my hometown
Parks right next to Park when they open
that up baby I was in there like
swimwear oh yeah we used to go to it was
a racetrack before we used to go bet the
ponies oh my God oh my God you just
sounded like Duty that's pretty good I
can get it in like two seconds once in a
while yeah
um wait do you have underwear holes
underwear yeah the cameras I have the
red camera not red it's like orange camo
sheets
nope nope uh and I mean I was I was
wearing them yesterday they have so many
holes but they are so [__]
comfortable yeah they're boxer briefs
boxer briefs are the ones they they get
it in between the legs it looks like
[__] like uh piranhas got at them
it's [__] bad there's like little
holes everywhere
bad news
not sheets I'm talking about the no no
how long did it take any underwear I
don't care if there's sheath or [__]
Obama wear it doesn't matter you're
getting holes in them Obama's making
underwear he is now he is now time just
down 2.4 million dollar deal for
underwear and yeah these gave up pretty
quickly after that
um is that true I don't think it sure is
Buddy it sure is uh he's dressed like a
geisha what do you believe
when's the last time you went to a
museum
because
um enough said I saw ancient ruins a
week ago where's that your holes in your
seat
[Laughter]
it was a closed down Pizza Hut where'd
you see on Grease yeah Acro teary I went
there yeah
you went to Acro teary
maybe where is that where's that
Santorini no I wouldn't go to Santorini
it's raining didn't you feel at a place
there isn't that where like the hot like
Club no it's Mykonos yeah no no Mykonos
did you go to Athens and go all around
there yeah
that you went to ruins there now oh yeah
I did it what am I talking about I went
to the Acropolis and the Parthenon yeah
yeah something else something else
really is you can see how they were all
in psychedelics when they're thinking
about all that [__] you think I think so
we're like you hit this uh tree and it
created a [__] Zeus came out and
[__] neptuned out the I don't know
whatever the story is I think you're on
Psychic yeah I think that's a Disney
movie you walked all the way up there I
walked all the way up there Ari good for
you buddy walked all the way up there
[__] petrified how to get Medevac
down here
because it was it's all marble it's
slippery slippery on the way down it's
even worse dangerous he did it in
prescription cracks yeah but not a lot
of traction oh wow yeah but I walked all
the way up and all the way all the way
down let's get cheese
yeah it's fun up there huh though it's
awesome
life-changing very cool
other people use that word let me ask
you a follow-up question of that please
what way did it change your life
yeah you're right I've never gone
yeah there's that and there's uh oh
there's another word that they sell this
on Nick Cody's uh on poster for
Edinburgh once it was like um I forget
what the word is but it's like
ah [__] I forgot I should know it was
life-changing in the fact that I never
thought I would see something like that
it's awesome I never thought that I
would be in that be in a position where
I could go and do that yeah and I'm very
grateful though huh very going all the
way across the world seeing a [__]
wild ruins of a wild I love that I
thought it was cool as [__] it's it's
like uh Outlaw yeah it was [__] like
uh anarchists and [__]
there was a yeah there was some
literature on the walls yeah big big uh
what's it called what are those people
called Marxist yeah but um they have
them here but Tommy scum sort of commies
Fatima what is it antifa antifa ah but
it's like a different crew there okay
they're doing something there they're
not just like fat guys messing with old
people okay have you ever picked up a
penny as an adult yes I do it every time
I walk by opinion on heads I have to
pick it up
I have to have to why because it's good
luck and I I feel like if I don't
something bad'll happen to me
wow yeah that's an onion and if it's on
I have to I have to pick it up and I
have to look at the date and put it in
my pocket away from my other change and
if it's on head if it's on Tails I don't
walk over it I walk around I have to
Blink 18 times and never call my mother
again
too [__] no no what are the things you
got like that Superstition that you're
just like you just got to do it uh knock
on wood you knock on wood I knock on
wood what about salt oh yeah [__]
shoulder oh yeah left
always left no I have my own things but
if you spill salt you got to throw it
over your left shoulder what are your
things I'd rather not get into it at
this point yes told you about the
diarrhea thing I told you about the
holes in my underaroos when you
accidentally drop a load inside a woman
you go
[Laughter]
okay that's what I do you yeah
I do it's bad news bad news
okay let's see what else we got has
anyone ever done this to you guys uh no
no I mean people come in like hey I had
one question one question you know not a
full legal pad more than one question
have you ever brought
store-bought food to a party and claimed
it as your own
that's that's nice no somebody got
caught doing that though I can't quite
remember it
they said they made them and then like
my aunt or something came over and
whispered in my ears at Costco how did
you know you can tell you can tell if
you've had them before you're like this
is a thing but the person did go to
Great Lengths because she
um it turned out after she left they
tried to figure out how she what she did
um she got regular cookies they think
from a store and then bake them a little
more baked them so they just slightly
off yeah like that they're a little like
a little burnt on them devious yeah to
go to that length yeah cover up that
you're just like it's cool man you just
bought it I also just say hey calls them
and then my thing just Spruce them up is
this and then a little bit if you're
going to a party and you're like I made
a I made a a macaroni salad oh cool and
if you're like hey I brought entrance
like oh cool yeah you don't have to be
like wow it's like and I tell you what
most grocery stores their little Bakery
section are great they're cookies and
all that stuff are [__] fantastic can
I tell you a hidden secret you guys can
all do at home please or your car
whatever you're listening to this go to
a bakery you can get whatever you want
written on a kick whenever you want
sure yeah so what are you 11. yeah I
don't think that's a state so far I
don't think that's a secret dude go to a
cake you got hey I'm going are you in
the Illuminati Jesus this is a uh 33rd
birthday and I'm like I'm going over
there and I'm like H and then you open
up your cake oh thanks and it goes shut
up H sure what a [__] treat I got one
for Rogan for his 40th or 50th birthday
party we got a cake at Mrs Fields or one
of those big cookies you love those
brought to them on stage
[Music]
opening on stage she was like Jesus
Christ now we're demonetized yeah yeah
well you can believe that this cost me
30 bucks Ari you know what didn't cost
me Kansas City Indianapolis St Louis and
Louisville uh with special guest team
renazi and Ryan O'Neal in November
tickets at all you should fear.com
I have more questions for you guys
how many questions do you usually come
up with forgets what how many questions
do you guys come up with for guests uh
usually probably about the same amount
but we have less costume changes
it's so hot in this [__] thing I mean
that's crazy oh can I tell you I bought
this in Edinburgh at a uh what's that in
Scotland yeah Thrift Store hi but if you
could have given me a million yes and uh
right at the time we were walking around
it was me Dulce Sloan I forget a couple
other people and we're talking about
cultural appropriation it was like I
don't know it's like well it's all about
respect whatever she was like why'd you
buy this I'm like well cool I don't know
and right then we passed because
Edinburgh and everyone's out having a
good time we passed a bunch of Chinese
people and they saw it and they were
like this and she goes and she looked at
them we were all of them and they go oh
nice I was like respect respect there
you go it's a nice one yeah dice taught
me this about smoking cigarettes in an
indoor place oh
[Laughter]
we're at a mall in Los Angeles and he's
he took out a cigarette and started
smoking I'm like what the [__] are you
doing dude it was fine security guard
comes over pretty fast he goes hey hey
it's yeah what are you doing no
absolutely not it's indoors he goes oh
my bad damps on it puts it out get your
couple drags though get your couple
drags get your fix just keep it moving
Don't Mess no muss
huh I remember when you could smoke in
balls do you really yeah I think so I
remember my parents ripping a heater I
remember meeting long the Leo mall I
could I remember you could still smoke
it because I remember them seeing them
on the floor like that uh kept on like
on that yeah yeah on that aisle so gross
Idol as a guy who likes a heater I don't
like smoking inside I love smoking
inside an inside cigarette seems like
you're doing something wrong now Ari's
literally trapped inside a bit right now
oh my God I'm trapped out a bit ride it
out come on commit to the bed oh my God
okay you're right you're right you're
right we only got two hours left serves
you're right
okay okay
reported on your knitted hat you dope
you [__] bozo freaking ass shrinking
in my head
don't burn anything Ari no all right you
can't or you can't count smoke that all
right Jesus Christ
I is this your friend do you ever lights
light matches to burn off [__] smells
100 I think it's gross as [__] it's the
best no pun intended you think it's
gross I hate that combination that
sulfur smell and oops 100 wrong he's a
hundred it's so good when you walk into
a bathroom and it sounds like that no
it's just gross but it's better than
what it would have been just use [__]
air freshener
no that's fake that's like uh air
fresheners both together matches matches
this year out scientific it takes their
out of the fusion or osmosis do you
think I'm listening to either one of you
you're getting shot down at a Starbucks
and he's dressed like nine people it's a
nuke it's a new car
it takes this damn it you're you've got
a good point
you two are incredible you don't want to
be aligned with me I'll tell you that
for anybody you stink
oh I love this episode
you guys are so [__] high and mighty
and you're dumb [__] judging horses
what are you talking about how does it
feel now how does it feel now well guys
it's actually quite refreshing let me uh
let me go over all this let me see
let me see where it's standing by the
way Kent City Indianapolis St Louis
Louisville uh Lincoln Des Moines
Milwaukee Pasadena Brea San Diego
Sacramento oh I'd say around happy
Tucson whatever okay
Cleveland wrong side of History tour
wrong side of History tour on sunday.com
uh have you ever moved a bar factory on
a plan you both said yes I said no okay
yes and I know you know what's a fun
thing to do with barf bags on planes if
you're on them if I'm chewing gum yeah
I'll put it in the barf bag and then
I'll just seal it closed oh I've done
that just in case someone gets jammed up
later on being interested you know
bastard me an interesting Tino notable
redheaded inbred have said that we want
to put on the inside and I suggest
everyone do this
with your own social media whatever our
email they don't clean the insides they
don't see insides of the the pouches
leave just go hey they didn't drop they
didn't wash this on us on a Post-It note
take Post-it notes with you on your
carry-on bag
this they didn't clean this at Ari
shaffir man put it on there put it up
without context if somebody who doesn't
know who you are just join this podcast
at this moment you are a crazy person
hey do you know what Confucius says okay
let's move on
uh you said have you ever smoked within
six feet of a child in a stroller both
of you said yes yes that's true
wow weird garbage wow
have you ever drunk a fireball both of
you said yes yes
everybody what's the difference between
effect and effect both of you did know
the difference yeah did know the
difference and he used concur he used to
concur yes I didn't know the difference
but that just sounded really good what
the [__] was that did you guys just get
your first wireless phone the cops are
here to get you
so you both didn't know and as I'm doing
this right now I realize they'd be more
upset if you guys were classy than
trashy so you both did know so you're
trying to you're trying to spin us to be
classy lots of questions here by the way
this will be the fourth time Ari loses
awesome question here did you a family
uh ever receive as a gift uh fruitcake
and one of you did say no okay
interesting have you seen every Fast and
Furious uh both of you said no I said
yes oh every Fast and Furious yeah uh do
you keep food in your car
does it feed into your narrative uh did
you ever wear do you wear an undershirt
when you're in a suit what if you said
no is there a that's a fat guy thing
though you can't hold that against me
that wasn't a question
hahaha
is there a two liter of soda in your
fridge no both of you said no but you
didn't ask if there was a three liter
gotcha two liters are for [__] sorry
have you ever picked up a penny as an
adult and uh Kevin here said no
interesting so you guys know
note yourself guards
okay let's get it over there have you
ever uh have your credit cards been
rejected you both said yes you ever
snuck a cigarette do I get bonus points
for being rejected today yeah you do get
bonus points like a hundred bonus points
there you go points for that
I'm the most successful I have ever been
and I'm still defaulting on my credit
card bills
when was the last time yours got
declined
okay I don't know what's going on out
there
the people who made the credit cards
your people did make the credit cards
yeah
well okay let me do this real quick
I hear sirens I hear banging I think
somebody's coming to get him
yeah without a shirt on
one two four
you look like an Asian tugboat captain
[__] you H [__] yeah
all right well you have interesting uh
stats here would you what do you come up
with
you guys uh uh unfortunately uh-huh
I believe that's for you nope yep yep
somebody thoughts on it alone get them
out of there
they're both very classy thank you these
two guys are frogs and they are both
classy and I want it no these two classy
individuals have no idea what to talk
about in terms of trash we're actually
talking British accents
I don't know them when they're off here
they have an
Automated machine to give you tea
Automated machine it's a Carrick
okay
laughs
and so concludes this episode of are you
garbage in which we found out that the
hosts of this show Kevin and H not his
full name whatever his real name may be
frauds I tell you ah you got us called
Ari shaffir Ari shaffir everybody let's
go it's a shame you're not on tour yet
again I am on tour actually the wrong
side of History tour hold on you know
what's crazy what's that the sunglasses
Thailand it really pulls it together you
would have had so much more credibility
you looked you look great yeah damn it
that really ties the whole thing
together the whole time
let's smoke a heater you look like ZZ
bottom
Every Girl's Crazy about a weird Dress
Man
getting the wrong side of History tour
Mr Ari shaffir do yourself a favor go
see him he's one of the absolute best
and we love him Ari thank you so much
what do you got for him oh no oh please
thanks for having me of course thanks
for coming by yeah I'd like to promote
if I could pretty sure we lost our
security deposit anything guys Shakira's
old albums are really good
that's just funny
uh guys we are all over the road
obviously shows are selling out so oh
yeah
putting your home you're lost and found
clothes on
I bought this up a man who's now dead
yeah you killed them probably it does
look like you just got bed bugs
what I can wear a lot of stuff was
infected this is all I had left it's the
only thing the bugs didn't take that
[__] was a storage I just bought a
storage he looks like he invented bed
bugs
we're all over the place uh we're adding
a third show in Toronto I believe get
tickets for that wear suits for these
classy individuals at Toronto where you
guys in Toronto uh the um uh what's it
called the Regal no the Royal the Royal
Theater the Royal Theater we're doing it
we're doing three there and then we
added a second show at the Fillmore in
Philly that's more than halfway sold out
that will sell out get those [__]
tickets we're all over the road Buffalo
Pittsburgh Toronto uh uh yeah just get
your [__] tickets again we love
seeing everybody on the road we'll see
you out there we'll see you next weekend
peace peace drink milk with dinner come
on
laughs